hey everyone black panther is now in
theaters and we are here with our review
do you think this movie lived up to the
hype
does it deserve the 97 or whatever it is
now percent fresh score on Rotten
Tomatoes how exactly does this movie
change the game for the MCU is it okay
for me to dress up as Black Panther for
Halloween and probably not but we're
gonna dig deep into all these questions
well not that last one we're gonna dig
deep and all the questions you have
about this movie
get to our review but first welcome guys
to new rockstars news
it's our deep dive and do all the
biggest stories from this week we're
also gonna talk about this new I don't
know if you saw this Incredibles 2
trailer that came out we're going to
talk about Deadpool 2 super funny
trailers and promo material will they
pay off or when this movie has to come
out in theatres and get people to get
their butts in seats we'll talk about
all that I'm Erik Bosse and join me at
this table are my hosts in crime
oh I'm Sam basher hey i'm philip molina
and my dog is here today so if you hear
barking it's Erica but if you hear
growling that's my dog yeah and you can
just like call the dog just screaming
your TV screen in the well let's move on
from canines to felines and get started
with our top story
guys black panther we've all seen the
movie the three of us at this table
we're gonna dive deep into the reasons
why we love it suppose maybe you get to
a couple gripes that we might've had
with it now we'll try to warn you if we
get to any spoilers for like the ending
of the big stuff that happens in it but
it's best for you guys to just consider
this a spoiler review just so you don't
get mad at us a know what go watch it
movie guys I mean I assume based off of
ticket sales someone either you've
already seen it but let's get started
what do we love about this movie what
worked for us everything but no like
there's there's a lot to love about this
movie and for me the top the top thing
besides like actually there's so much
the price but for me the thing that like
left me thinking about it more was what
Conda and that is trying to like
basically encapsulate the culture that
we got to see the spirituality the music
the fashion the technology like every
bit of it that you got to see even from
like like I'm sure you'll see some
certain characters having that that
little that does a little tiny like
nuggets you get throughout the movie are
so fantastic and it made me want to
watch it again to see what I'm not
catching in the scenes and you don't
think we got that level of detail with
that small town and Thor I've never seen
a better set ever in these movies oh
it's like buildings living quarters it's
just diner bowling alley that's it yeah
this movie needs to win awards for a
costume for production designs yeah I'm
like it is a complete world with you
know it reminds you of how george RR
martin can go back you know thousands of
years in the lineage of Game of Thrones
characters it kind of almost has that
energy to it where it's like there's so
much history here that we're not even
aware of but they are aware of and I
think that is kind of the only way that
they it was a big task to to honor
African culture yeah and it kind of is
like and you're gonna do it in like a
superhero movie you're gonna pull up by
treating it in a way that really they
just said look African cultures really
rich and and it has a very long history
to it even calling it the birthplace of
man in that and the film to that did tap
into the idea like damn yeah this place
Wakanda or not these places are real and
they're this level of beautiful yeah it
was interesting you brought up George or
America's areas like a game of Thrones
and I would even say like Tolkien asked
like level of world building in this the
right thing it's like compared to like
because I was trying to think we've seen
the MCU like like build out to the space
side of things and that's totally
creative thing to do whatever they want
excuse me or like Lord of the Rings or
Game of Thrones is a better example
because more people are into that right
now but there's something like there's
like a dystopian part of that or with
space there's nothing really for you to
connect with so you see something
beautiful and you're like well I like
looking at that but I don't really want
to go there this though I want to go
there I want yeah be in this world more
yeah maybe that's what other people feel
with other big sci-fi or fantasy genre
like books or movies but finally like I
got it I got what that appeal it
compared to a lot of the other MCU
movies that had come out like looking at
this town of Wakanda and the way the
palace was laid out and shuri's lab like
this is something that I could conceive
Marvel ever turning into like a theme
park that I could go visit you know the
way that they did with like cars land or
Radiator Springs in in California
Adventure the way they did with Harry
Potter movies like they created this
world that yeah I would want to go visit
that that'd be fun to like walk around
that town they they put a lot of thought
into how this place would conceivably
evolve of a vibranium meteorite crash
there if they had this art heart-shaped
or a bivariant vibranium can do anything
it can be a magnets magnets yeah so
there's a ton of world building and not
just in the production design in a
setting but also like in the ensemble
like this is one of the first MCU movies
I mean you could say that about Avengers
maybe guardians but I think it worked
really well for those movies in the same
way it worked really well for Black
Panther it was a real team win you know
like as much as I like chadwick boseman
in this movie he I would say got
overshadowed by some of his supporting
cast members most yeah yeah he like it
was Sheree is for me stole the movie but
in Baku has had such a great supporting
role and denies character oh yeah okay
yeah oh yeah yeah she she was the stand
up for me because I because I don't
watch The Walking Dead this is my first
I think this is my first like she's
really known for The Walking Dead until
now yeah hopefully this really I mean it
should help her get like more roles
because she's fantastic
also Stirling Kate brown because I am
about to start this is us and I'm like
of course that'd be fantastic so
watching this I was like even for like
cuz he doesn't play the biggest role but
when you do see him whoever he's
interacting with I'm like this is so
good
yeah I know we want to talk about kill
miner in a second one of my favorite
parts the movie but just touching on
what both we were talking about with the
generals but also just almost the
societal structure and the hierarchy
especially with the military and also
you know they had the merchant class and
and though their leaders and stuff all
of that structure it's kind of the world
building we were talking about but the
fact that it not only was there but it
also made us like get it in under two
hours and start rooting for the
different
tribe and stuff when we actually care
about you know the gorilla tribe
mountain we like like we didn't know
what the hell that was you know an hour
earlier but like after we're like oh my
god the reuniting because they did such
a great job for me especially with with
the what is it the kingsguard equivalent
oh sure the dorm a lodging yeah yeah
fantastic but yeah my favorite part is
Erik kill monger yeah if we want to
discuss them at all sure yeah let's see
about the villain I think on so many
levels Michael B Jordan brought so much
to this movie you gotta think about
other I mean it's easy to look at other
MC villains to talk about where they
they failed but this is one of the first
times I've seen in the Marvel world but
also in really any memorable movie from
recent years where the villains goals
are sympathetic Eric hill monger in D
jakka is is a original name is trying to
do something that we almost understand
like he's trying to give power back to
an oppressed race it's run like a game
of Thrones standpoint you've definitely
rooted for this storyline that's
happened before it's like it's almost
like aria like she got just read by
somebody and like this is his revenge
tale and it's like because we're seeing
it from wakandan child's point of view
it's like this is something that's bad
but it makes total sense and he has some
of the best scenes with yet without
other like main cast maybe it's like him
by himself or him with just one of the
other supporting characters just seeing
him get explored and when you find out
about like what he's been through he's
extremely formidable but you know in a
way that you can understand instead of
saying he's like what a nose he's got
space rocks and they make time Bend and
it's like alright whatever but it's like
for him it's like no that's terrifying
he's genuinely terrifying yeah I think
that his there's so many good things I
could say about Michael B Jordan
performance about the characters
backstory about his motivations I'm
super in agreement with you that those
motivations are ones that we actually
are like he kind of has a point like if
we could go back and we could change
slavery and stuff would
we if we could give them the tools yeah
and then in some ways don't some people
feel like they're still suffering the
same kind of oppressions so shouldn't we
empower them that's right sorry I but
like leaving the theater I was like I my
thought I had two main thoughts
beautiful movie I loved it
but also there's a lot of ideas that are
brought up here that like no other MC
movie would ever dare touch in any
capacity but also it's like is like is
this a fair it made me have like a
philosophical debate in my head where
I'm like great is this a fair thing to
bring up like but if it is like that
it's okay take out what Conda for a
second and just think of any other
tragedy that's happened currently and
like people being you know stagnant not
doing it for anybody because they're
being isolationist or they're just
saying like well that's their problem or
whatever it's it was it was heavy and it
was dealt with such grace and also they
simplified it enough so that basically
everyone could get it and without saying
without like pointing fingers everywhere
they basically get to use fictional
places like would-be villain instead of
like like white people or other people
like that you could yeah it wasn't a
race war yeah but real quick I'll say
two things just that if you whatever you
you were just saying on your rewatch and
I would tell you guys at home to try
this ask yourself does he actually
convince t'challa to change the way he
treating Wakanda amongst the world is it
because of the previous arguments or is
it because of kill mongers arguments and
the moments that they're connecting with
at the end of the film and if so did he
win I mean he didn't entirely win he
didn't get exactly what he wanted but
does he come out of this actually
winning this movie but the other thing I
just want to say real quick that's one
of my favorite things that this villain
does and he does so well is he changes
the rhythm of the scenes that he's in so
cool because the scenes are you start to
get you know very consistent like well I
object kind of like form formality to
the kingdom and its palace intrigue
which isn't for everyone and he comes in
he's like sup auntie you're like yeah
it's like you'd like pulls you out of it
and every single thing he says it's not
just that oh that sounds the like how we
are used to talking or hearing it also
is just like a chaos bolt like thrown
into a machine yeah they're just like oh
disrupts everything yeah like that you
bring up rhythms
because like even like during the like
the Black Panther ceremony for like
choosing who's king there's like a
rhythm to it and you kind of get in that
rhythm as the movies going like because
music plays is such a big part in all of
this but also just how like that the
cadence of their voice is like in like
their accents there's like there's a up
and a down to it so him coming in and
just totally ruining you got a that's a
very good point yeah the movie
definitely changes when Michael B Jordan
walks into frame and like this is a
third movie Michael B Jordan has made
with the director Ryan Coogler and it's
really been three for three after Creed
a couple years ago and a fruit peel
station a couple years before that it's
been I haven't seen a director connect
with a villain in this Marvel world ever
since in a superhero movies since Nolan
with Heath Ledger and the Joker in that
when Heath Ledger walked in to frame he
completely changed the dynamic of the
movie in the way that kill monger does
in this movie he's a villain that almost
overshadows the rest of the movie and
you are kind of in a weird way want to
see him succeed even though you know on
a moral standpoint he cannot succeed it
would just change the game too much the
Filip brought up an interesting point of
like the who wins the debate right and I
think yeah that is an interesting
question it's this movie in a lot of
ways connects to its history of
african-american cinema and I was
reminded to do the right thing if you
watch that movie that brought up an
interesting debate within the civil
rights movement between the Martin
Luther King's civil rights followers and
followers of Malcolm X who believed
should African Americans militarized and
fight back or is a non-violent approach
of the way to go and I felt that kind of
dynamic playing out between T'Challa and
kill monger it's a very very aware
afro-futurist movie and very aware of
its themes even like kill mongers final
words before he what a very dark how he
kept thinking about like I mean reboiler
warning he says bury me at sea because
like to be buried with his ancestors who
jumped off the ships because death is
better than bondage like what I like a
very dark but very like understandable
for his character a point of view to
have it like I
the character was definitely very aware
of the the philosophy of that of that
which which so argument the the
motivation for a villain and a lot of
times an MCU is vengeance right you know
you fired me mm-hmm
Doctor Strange yeah that's basically
they have you simplify a little bit
added demon in there and you're good but
also this just wanted to point this out
because I love Creed I'm watching many
times it has a very similar structure
for Michael P Jordan's character in both
films where you open with child version
of Michael B Jordan not having a father
and like or like losing something like
that and it's he's a kid he's confused
he doesn't know about his future or his
heritage and then later you revisit that
scene over and over again throughout the
movie ryan coogler did the same thing i
I haven't seen Fruitvale station because
I I know what the story's about and part
of me is like it's kind of like I
haven't watched like Schindler's List
it's like it's like I know that this is
not going to be a very happy thing for
me to watch but it's gonna be a very
good movie so I haven't watched it so I
don't know if that's the same but it was
fun to see that mirroring between Creed
and Black Panther yeah and then just
real quick on this one Kate Brown thing
but I firmly in that scene it's just
another instance really like he's got
some good points man actually no talking
I even though they both look like early
90s rappers which I thought was like a
great choice because early 90s and they
had the gold chains and everything
perfect which a quick thing my brother
dressed me exactly like that for like
six years shaved off part of my eyebrow
yeah it's a good I think it's a sign of
a good movie or at least of a complex
movie where no one is wrong you know
where no one is like just flat-out
evil or crazy there's like everyone's
coming from somewhere you who are like
wrong but they're like or doing wrong
things there's like there's wrong some
curious if they maybe there's similar oh
no they're doing wrong they're making
wrong decisions there's there's like
morally if you tried to take out the
culture of and you just look at what the
act is that's a bad thing to do so
where's way more strings attached to it
that like need to be examined
but they still do wrong things but no
that's the best point of this movie is
that at the end of the day you're like
bad guy
but like right yeah I mean even easier
to see with Daniel clears character
where he we see him actually go like man
I don't want a side with this guy but it
just makes so much sense
yeah yeah well so we've talked a lot
about things that worked for us are
there any gripes that we have I mean
it's a great movie it's not perfect so
CGI is a big thing for me because I saw
IMAX and he didn't do IMAX 3d and I
think thankfully they didn't because of
CGI his like the two things that stuck
out a lot were a lot of a lot of big
sweeping shots like entering Wakanda
awesome like really really good but then
there's like it's I think it's like near
the end when they're on like a waterfall
there's a scene where like outside like
like from the edge of the cliff it looks
like an image that's just copy pasted
onto the waterfall and it's it's really
hard to look at and also sometimes their
heads look like they're floating inside
their masks I said you know what's
interesting is that the sky had an it
was so vibrant and such a bright blue
that it has a little bit of a chroma key
effect where feels like it's not really
there even though it actually might have
been there but they might have pushed
the color correction and make it a
little bit more extreme because they
talked a lot about the skies in Wakanda
and the only over time I see drivers
like in the only moment where it stood
out to me was when they're both
plummeting into the mine or whatever
yeah it isn't awesome like one take but
it is pretty just like it's one of those
moments that kind of like to me switches
to like alright and we're in video game
for you know a good minute or so and
then we're out of video game again it's
the Marvel II stuff that sometimes
didn't work weirdly for a Marvel movie
it's the stuff when they like like
wouldn't recommend IMAX for this even
though I'm glad there's some shots like
when they enter Wakanda that's awesome
but the opening scene in the dark when
they're like there's just flashes of
gunfire and then like him walking in the
dark it was like you can't but I was
sitting far back and you can't like
focus on what's happening on the screen
so that was a bit of a negative but it
but the character the character moments
in this are just so good that sometimes
I'm like I wish we spent more time with
that even though we didn't even have
that much action in this movie but to be
fair some of the action this movie was
awesome
South Korea chase scene
believable yeah I'll have a mildly hot
take em I'll take ready for this my
health it no it's gonna make you feel
just fine maybe the glass of milk settle
that I think that if I had to find a
weakness and I really enjoyed this movie
so I don't want to but if I had to it
would be to chala mm-hmm I think that if
it were not for chadwick boseman the
character would not have communicated of
being very unique or interesting or
different in any way he has this amazing
ability to like behind his eyes kind of
give you a little bit like I'm a little
cocky like I've got I've got a little
complexity to me but for the most part
he had which off often this happens with
regal characters they they're muted but
it was just like oh man I would love to
see him go through some pains and learn
who he really is and it feels like we
have to see that in the sequel now but
honestly if he if he had to earn back
his right to reclaim the throne instead
of just you know take the purple flower
and then just like kind of show up again
like it's if instead there had been a
short sequence there because I movie
actually flew by for me so I think there
was room for a short sequence there of
him being like no too bad you
technically were defeated you do not
have a the you're not rightful heir
anymore and then he has some other way
earn it back or something I've really
tested him and we saw man this guy is
interesting this guy has really neat
take and he was pretty mild to me
everyone else especially just next to
someone like kill monger or any of the
other characters that we're like oh my
god you have your so vivid and there's
so much going on I mean even I'm
blanking on her name too but according
yeah the relationship that she has and
how she very specifically identifies her
honor is more important than her love
yeah and I was like god that's so
interesting for a character to know
themselves that well her sister and his
mother even everyone knows himself so
well and he just kind of is just I'm not
gonna say one-dimensional cuz that's
unfair to him but he's definitely not
three diamond yeah if we're gonna
compare kill monger to Heath Ledger's
the Joker in the Dark Knight I think
it's fair to compare T'Challa to Bruce
wayne/batman for
that movie in that like it's not that
he's bad he's completely fine and the
role he's just a little too stoic
there's that bit of an internal struggle
but it's it's less of his story as I
think it is the the whole group story
and what kind of story and you can tell
by the end of movie just like it seemed
like Batman was convinced by Joker of
his philosophy it's it seems like the
villain had a big role in changing the
hero it seems like a kill monger had a
bigger role in changing T'Challa to
change from his isolation its point of
view to an attitude of well let's see if
we can help the world just not in the
same extremist way that kill monger
wants to do it let's do it in a
nonviolent peaceful way that we can help
people rather than give people
instruments of destruction if I had a
grape yeah I would understand I agree
with Bill being a little underwhelmed at
least compared to the other emcee origin
stories we've gotten where the hero it's
like oh I immediately want to see him in
another movie I want to see to trial in
another Black Panther movie I don't
necessarily need to see him right away
mix with the other MCU guys I want to
get to know more of this guy's world and
see what kind of ruler he would be in
Wakanda I do want more of his supporting
cast in with the MC which is like I'm
just thinking from The Avengers infinity
war trailer I'm like why in the world
would aliens be like and here it's like
a challenge yeah pick Iowa just
somewhere in Iowa you'd be fine but I
did want to point out that I did while I
agree with you that the chawla seems to
be like the weakest and like I think we
all love the movie so I think it's okay
yeah but I think Zuri the Forest
Whitaker's character might be a little
less flushed out he gets a fun orgeous
sure but when like I would say he's got
a little bit more of an arc and my guilt
that he's riding with or at least
expresses a little moral I just
or at least the same road to true but I
just didn't emotionally connect with him
as much as I wanted to but I did like
that we got a pretty clear arc for
T'Challa of wrestling between staying
isolation isolationist and choosing to
open their doors and he at the same time
shows it through his clothing and also
the
he like talks to different people it
it's very craftily done and I do like
everything you're saying about Eric kill
monger bringing that up but also I think
they did a good job of having Nokia his
lover X or whatever however they not
yeah I like that she also has a similar
belief that way like we can kind of grow
from there and also this there's another
good guy that's you know that's gonna
stick around for a little bit right and
like and it also believes that as well
and sorry I'm just gonna say I was I
teared up many different times with some
of Eric come on with Eric kill mongers
soon as well as your final shot and the
first post-credit scene like both of
those that gave T'Challa like the an
awesome moment in the movie that
post-credits scene that gives a that
speech yeah it's like it's so man Ryan
Coogler is very good with words he's
very good at getting a point across like
me and themes though and I think boy if
it helps your point at you you just have
some man made me realize something I
like about the movie now a lot and it's
you know we're we're saying maybe child
didn't have the most interesting arc for
himself
but you're right it was about should we
bring Wakanda to the greater world and I
think that that actually is a little bit
of Ryan Coogler kind of like saying it's
this is about bringing what kind what
kind of the Greater MCU and this is his
own challenge too and it's almost a
Kevin Feige arc right now is do we bring
in Wakanda when it's being totally
genuine area it's completely politically
charged to aim so much attention I mean
literally the movie is coming out within
days of people talking about whether or
not these are [ __ ] countries it's a
very charged moment to do it it's very
scary to say like here's our take on
Africa mm-hmm signed Disney you know
like that's extremely scary to do and so
the fact that we're all gushy about what
Conda first of all it tells us damn they
were successful on introducing us this
but we should be comparing this actually
to the way that maybe the Avengers and a
little bit of Iron Man but introduced us
to New York and then spider-man's
goodness different levels of New York
and then you know the defenders are also
giving us New York but there's still
more New York don't worry
I think guardians was like here's MCU
the MCS take on space right the fact
that we're talking about maybe the most
successful introduction to a new setting
of the MCU is is what kind of this that
means this movie is like blew it out of
the park because until this what was the
MCU it was New York right it was a small
town somewhere that Thor lands Germany a
large general space not a Germany and TV
shows especially and then what's the
place that gets picked up in the probiem
and it's gonna like there wasn't a lot
of it's not a rich tapestry the the
geography of the mt hotham the world map
the MCU is pretty boring and then
suddenly they just added this huge
glowing stone and I loved it I did that
so well and a major praise like I some
CGI didn't work but the opening origin
for Wakanda and like biennium in general
it's like that was the coolest origin
ever it's basically they try to they
just took weird Man of Steel Kryptonian
Tech from it's like where it's like a
fun idea it's not really working yes and
and like they they built on it and made
it work so makes no sense if you try to
like pick it apart but it's very cool
magnets well guys let us know what you
thought of Black Panther how does this
rank for you against your past favorite
MCU movies did you have any more issues
and maybe we're overlooking cuz we loved
it so much but yeah let us know down in
the comments below I think this is
something that we are all gonna want to
go rewatch again because there's just so
much to really dig into in this movie
and yeah we'll be doing more videos on
it in the coming weeks keep an eye out
for a breakdown that we do on it but for
now let us move on to this week's trivia
question we are going to stay in with
the theme of Black Panther here
and let's see what we got okay so the
question is in Captain America's Civil
War what were the final words of two
challahs father came to chaka in his
speech to the UN before he was killed in
the bombs explosion Kyla's got some
thoughts this is we're looking for the
final words that he said they had that
father/son moment and then I think he
was in the in the middle of the speech
okay looks like we got some option
answers here make sure to write your
name on it now later in this video we're
going to reveal what the correct answer
is and the winner has decided by our
judges whoever gets the closest answer
will get to do our sign off goodbyes at
the end of the video do whatever dumb
voice or character that they're trying
out I mean while the loser will have to
cleverly rip fun or in other news
headlines will actually talk more about
Black Panther and get to this vide get
to this answer later on but so yeah
write down your answer in the comments
below and see if you're right at the end
of the video
all right everybody Pixar's Incredibles
2 as a new trailer the sequel appears to
follow up the events from the first 2004
movie exploring a new career opportunity
for Elastigirl and mr. Incredibles
trials raising baby Jack Jack as his
unhealthy powers terrorized the
household so let's break down this
trailer and point out all the big
details that you might have missed what
do you say guys yes please alright first
off this movie looks like it'll pick up
immediately where the first movie left
off in its final scene the family
responding to an attack by the
Underminer
by the way that's Pixar voice over actor
regular John Ratzenberger doing the
voice there he does a cameo in every
movie and a detail that I actually find
interesting about this is the time
period The Incredibles takes place in a
alternate time period check out the cars
I always saw The Incredibles as set in a
kind of world that's removed from time
like kind of a classic Neil Futurist
aesthetic kind of like this the sixties
view of the future and the Jetsons kind
of thing now some people pointed out
that in the first movie Bob a mr.
credible reads a newspaper that's dated
May 16 1962
so that should explain to you why
everything is sixtieths 60-ish
design-wise it's just it's they're
consistent with it because some people
say well if you actually do the time
line it's like it's set in the 70s but
it's all they're just going for the 60s
aesthetic which i think is really fun
it's not something you really but after
you know this you'll probably look at
this now and be like wow everything all
the fashion all the the glasses that
they're reading the textbook so it's all
very 60s design but let's move on to
another detail that I noticed in this
trailer the new character voiced by Bob
Odenkirk his name is Winston
Dever he's a corporate hotshot clearly
modeled on own Kirk's character Saul
Goodman from better Breaking Bad in
better call Saul now this characters
wife is being played by Catherine Keener
or voiced by Catherine Keener her name
is Evelyn
Dever which is kind of a fun Tom Riddle
II play on words revealing probably what
her true nature is Evelyn Dever evil
endeavor we'll see what comes from that
there's also this bit with Bob trying to
help - with this new math homework new
math was actually the name given to a
progressive approach to math education
in the 50s and that was scrapped and I'm
sure if you're a parent today you can
probably relate to the new unfamiliar
strategies that schools are trying to
use to teach kids math it's like how was
math changed math is math and then
lastly check out the logo on elastic
girl's costume they restored elastic
girl's original logo which was a sleek
letter e combined with a letter G which
is part of original costume before she
mr. and she a mr. incredible got married
in that opening prologue scene in the
first Incredibles movie it's interesting
now that they choose to do away with her
lowercase I from The Incredibles family
logo on Edna moats costumes so do you
guys think this mean maybe Helen is
trying to reclaim her into that
individuality after years of playing
homemaker what do you guys think about
that and what do you guys think about
this trailer in general well I actually
reached The Incredibles this week
because I was just like I knew this was
gonna come out and I was like I've
happened I watched it one time as a
child in the theater and I don't really
remember a lot of it so rewatching it
was very fun because it just felt like
watching a brand new Pixar movie
it's amazing by the way if you guys
haven't watched in a while you should
definitely check it out but also picking
up right after is a really interesting
thing because during that movie the dad
is there he's being very selfish like
he's choosing to like go behind his wife
and his family's back so that he can
like relive the glory days mm-hmm
and also there's a fun there's a fun bit
in when they're talking about no capes
and they actually dropped one of the
dates that in 58 one of the that's when
that girl got sucked into the airplane
engine yeah but no I'm very excited I'd
like that she now gets the chance it's
basically showing that he learned his
lesson and is allowing like any not
allowing she's like he's just trying to
be a better parent and like he's gonna
take over like household duties while
she gets also with her chance to be a
superhero once again so I'm I'm down for
that
yeah it's uh it's interesting how
they're choosing to do this sequel and
that they're choosing to do it after
what is it
fourteen years later the listen tree
watches trailer and listen to the audio
from - and from violet they had to get
new voice actors to play those parts
because they had kids playing those
parts in 2002 or 2003 when they
initially the movie came out 2004 but
those those were kids they're adults now
they got kids who sound exactly like -
and violets amazing man he's a man of a
thousand voices but it's I'm surprised
that it took this long in fact that
we've gotten sequels to cars - Toy Story
- Finding Nemo Incredibles seemed like
it was set up for a single on and now
I've watching this and I've been
thinking you know why now and I feel
like well the first Incredibles kind of
came along right kind of in a very early
phase of the superhero movie true and it
was mostly still the Nolan movies is
what any was worth it was a fun kind of
like alternate take on that hmm but now
we've had this whole other wave of what
it means to be a superhero what
superhero films are like so that's kind
of what I'm most curious about in the
same way that Deadpool came along just
at the right time at the height of the
seriousness it was Batman V Superman
right it was like around that time it's
like man that was the perfect moment for
Deadpool be like actually this can be
stupid - silly and I feel like maybe
that's a little bit about the time of
this like it felt like the right time on
the other side of multiple Avengers
movies and stuff now
what can the incredible say about being
a superhero unit especially now that
they do have things like the Avengers
and the guardians that talk about
superhero team
analysis that taken to for your family
and now this is you know returning to
the original superhero family in a way
I'm really curious to see what kind of
nods are gonna be especially since they
share a universe yeah in a way you know
yeah and the Pixar extended universe is
extremely dense and everything's making
reference to each other I know we did a
video that went to like the logic of the
Cars universe you did and then you guys
actually made a video explaining the
possibility of how all these Pixar
movies could be connected but yours is
great because you talked about the
religious aspect of it oh my god oh yeah
cars Pope so what does that mean don't
think about it too hard kind of fun it's
a fun thought experiment so check out
the video we've also done videos on
other Pixar properties including a full
breakdown of cocoa which is one of my
favorite movies from last year oh yeah
let us know what you think about this
trailer what are you most excited about
about about Incredibles
2 and yeah make sure to subscribe to the
new rock stars for deep dives into Pixar
and all the other movies that you love
thank you guys
well let us move on to another story
that came out this week I don't know if
you guys saw this so Deadpool - the
upcoming sequel in which Deadpool
team-up with cable or butt heads with
cable we'll see exactly that goes and of
course is featured a hilarious
promotional campaign with a number of
tongue-in-cheek posters and trailers
that are mostly just like comedy
sketches with a really just a few
seconds of actual action from the movie
now of course is a similar marketing
strategy to the one from the first film
in 2016 which included billboards
promoting itself as a romantic comedy to
watch on a watch with a date on
Valentine's I was gazing yeah and the
strategy totally worked worked out for
them big-time Deadpool was the highest
grossing Valentine's Day movie ever and
one of the most profitable movies of
that year but now there's an article in
Forbes suggesting that for the sequel
promos to emphasize comedy / superhero
action might not work out as well just
because comedy sequels historically
don't make as much money whereas really
the sky's the limit for superheroes
sequels now for fans of the comic and a
franchise of course so how we're gonna
see this movie regardless of what the
promos are but for mainstream audiences
do you think the first Deadpool's
rom-com
CEL was one time gimmick that worked or
is it like the meta humor and comedy
approach is really the only way you can
truly market a Deadpool movie given what
the characters legacy is yeah like
reading that Forbes article and seeing
the the title whatever I have to say
that definitely like shut up shut up
shut up you are so wrong that has
nothing shut up because because I'll be
like boy this is Deadpool and it is
absolutely not only just what worked
marketing wise if we have to look at it
from a business perspective which like I
get at your Forbes so you have to look
at a business perspective but I don't
want to but I'll say the marketing of a
film about a character whose most
famously known for breaking the fourth
wall
I mean pissing Kyllo oh I get it like
his thing is that he breaks the fourth
wall what is beyond the fourth wall of a
film the machinations around a film the
business the filmmaking the the shooting
of it the marketing and so of course yes
he has to completely influence and take
over the marketing and that's a nice
reminder to us don't worry we haven't
forgotten just because Deadpool is very
successful who he is and we're not gonna
make a movie that's just gonna try to
beat the amount of money we made from
the first movie we're gonna make a movie
it's even more Deadpool and that's the
only way to honor the first one and I'd
honestly don't I know there was action
in the first movie but if you really
like like gun in my head I think I
remember there was a car accident in the
beginning right yeah yeah I don't
structured around one chase sequence on
a freeway in Helicarrier at the end the
rest of it I mean what people remember
about that movie is that there was a lot
it was the character of Wade and
Deadpool and how he in the world that he
inhabits like it feels totally right
it's the people saw that movie whatever
got them in to the theater at the
beginning great they used the clever
marketing strategy after seeing that
movie it was a huge hit people
understand what Deadpool is now and it
would feel like a betrayal if they
didn't continue to market him this way
Deadpool is its own thing unfortunately
doesn't fit neatly within the categories
that the entertainment press has
established but that doesn't mean that
it will follow this same rule
that other movies have it's its own
popular thing that clearly defied
expectations the first time around it
probably will the second time I mean I
just want to laugh I just want to have a
good time and there's no one guys we're
all fans here no one knew who Deadpool
was like no one knew what no one had a
clue of what he was and then when they
saw some jokes in the trailer and then
they said they have nor anything for you
oh listen to them say the f-word in the
theater it's Superman there's a
superhero man he's gonna say the f-word
with the x-men there and it's like
that's kind of that was the main selling
points was the marketing yeah well let
us know what you think about this in the
comments below
but for now guys let us move on to our
needs no lightning round so as always we
have requested some questions from you
guys you were kind enough to tweet us
some responses to those or whatever you
want us to know or want us to answer so
I have compiled some and I'm gonna throw
them at my co-host so they have to
answer without hesitation as quickly as
possible
you guys ready by the way always the
best way to get the best answers don't
let his problem but that's how you get
the honesty right don't it's what they
want
ok here we go for Sam at 3 to 171 Alex
wants to know I guess it's a zip code
maybe I don't know who is the strongest
part that's the family The Incredibles
who is the strongest incredible I'm the
most powerful I like this but most
powerful probably it was violet she
could not only turn invisible but she
made it in an impenetrable force field
yes and yeah ok great for Philip at hmm
horny Wakanda wants to know what's in a
where could the soulstone be oh man
this is my question - okay it could
still be in Wakanda technically and it
could be still powering the trip to the
vision of the the undead on the plane
the spiritual mind
the Soul Train if it could still be
powering then there's still you know the
big glow the purple hue I feel like we
would have seen it though so yeah you
know it could still be in Wakanda and
that would make sense why they would go
there it also would mean that what three
of the stones are on earth which is
which is very frustrating if that's the
case so Oh my best other alternative is
if not at with the collector he knows
where it is and that yeah danos will go
to the collector and the collector will
tell them where it is yeah but man I
really want to know yeah possible we
won't even see it in the first don't
forget about it am i forget like right
there's a sixth one I mean Adam warlock
would be he's the one who possesses a
soul stone in the context it's not like
come until after the probably worth yeah
I would have met he could he might make
an appearance in the fourth one just
because he's if they can find a way to
introduce him between movies but there's
too many characters but maybe that's
just the MacGuffin to like keep going
into the next movie because it's like
it's also we all got a I'll probably dig
into this into other videos like keep an
eye out for that I want me to talk about
that more I will let's keep it up with
the lightning round here at Logan cret
13 lets me know who is your favorite
live-action Batman I will have to go
with Michael Keaton for this Bateman so
waiting B movie yeah yeah you can't
really go her I mean another one with
Christian Bale a couple things may be
wrong with Christian Bale Michael
Keaton's just great please is I mean
best Batman or best Bruce Wayne I don't
know it's Adam West I don't buy your
answer but I'll make you answer okay
well let's take a look at what we got in
the pipeline for videos coming out and
on the next week of course with Black
Panther out you will be seeing a full
movie breakdown a Black Panther all the
Easter eggs Ignis also Sam's got a video
coming out say do I worked on in a full
Avengers breakdown can
you probably have seen like a top 10 T
strikes you missed in adventures trust
me there are thousands I had an arrow
him down there's so many there's so
there's so many I watched the movie
three times last week just because well
one was for fun and then the two was for
the job but I that's very good also
check day had a blast also check out my
Captain America First Avenger one
because there's a lot of funny Easter
eggs for Phase two of Marvel in there ii
don't like it yeah and will also be of
course doing more stuff on black panther
we wanted we want to do more on the
amazing soundtrack in the movie the
music is awesome
and maybe a dressing though that mystery
of where the soulstone could be and some
other questions you might have had about
the movie coming out of it but now comes
the time for our 15-second shoutout
where each of us has 15 seconds to shout
out plug ramble about anything we want
and Sam why don't you start
well actually started doing movie
reviews on only stupid answers YouTube
channel they're very short so if you
like a little petite bite-sized movie
review that it has spoiler free I didn't
suggest go checking out to actually do
one for black panther it's very it's
very small so go check it out great
we get it you're fat for my 15 seconds
out out the comedy theater I've been
performing at for the past eight years
was unexpectedly closed because our
terrible owner in Chicago is a terrible
business person who gave us less than
two weeks notice uprooting hundreds and
hundreds of performers and this next
week is our final show a week so if you
live in the Los Angeles area and are
over the age of 21 although at this
point we don't care if we lose our
liquor license so you can just come
right in come to the iOS theater on
Hollywood Boulevard to come see some
amazing performers do one last show in
the theater that they love I'll be there
too I'm sorry
dark week for us but I'll find a new
place comedy doesn't have any one place
where it has to be performed right
alright and then my shout out is just
letting you guys know if whether you've
seen it before you want to see it again
get out it's gonna be in theaters again
yeah it's gonna be free and that's why I
wanted everybody know this for
Presidents Day it was Gordon peal said
you like you're welcome so I think like
he he traded in an awesome
the details are specifically at 7 p.m.
on Presidents Day so I like that we're
like talking like the whole or like so
what are you doing at 7 p.m. for watches
President's Day I'll be at parties but
take the whole party there because it's
free there's 55 AMC locations
specifically we can throw a link in the
description to figure out how to find
out which theater has free tickets there
first come first serve and you pick them
up that same day go see it again because
here's my favorite thing about it get
out is very good get out in theaters is
like on another level because he's weird
at fifth time seeing it in theaters when
I did we still got audience reactions
and I was part of that oh yeah or
cheering cuz it's just you get so into
it I'm so jealous I'm not gonna be able
to go but yeah we did but hey this time
you get to go in your Presidents Day
garb uh yeah definitely go check that
out that movie's great I think we have a
couple of videos on this channel where
we talk it was our pick for number one
movie of 2017 so yeah and hopefully
it'll win a couple of Oscars because
what a great film that was but finally
let's return to our trivia question that
we asked earlier let's see who was right
who was completely wrong right and yeah
okay so just remind you guys of what it
was asking the final words of two
challahs father to Chaka and Captain
America Civil War before the bomb went
off Phillip you want to start with Sam's
answer is beep boop you're King now beep
boop beep he's a robot with all time
he's all wrong I knew it okay so fill up
avenge me Simba broke what's that truck
doing outside oh well anyway boom yeah
does he say boom he was dropping the mic
from the speech yeah he's the truck that
is like a half a mile away well the
correct answer guys were pretty close
what Conda is proud to extend its hand
in peace translate beep oops irony in
screenwriting Bobby poop you're King now
boop boop beep this one me I wear the
beep boobs
alright so Sam wins B boobs who's it for
this man Jimmy Simba or was that truck
doing outside boom I think eventually
Simba's a loser okay well as I said
before Sam as the winner will do her
goodbyes and then Phillip you're gonna
help us out with our in other news
headlines that we didn't have time for
in this video I will actually read each
headline and Phillip you'll have to make
a joke at the end of each one to
cleverly riff on it well here we go
let's get started
in other news The Walking Dead's
upcoming episodes will feature the first
fully nude Walker so I you'll be I all I
can think in my head is of the phrase
flesh wound and I ate but it means dirty
things necrotic filth I want to bite
that get those ratings that just threw
me so much as an image I kept seeing and
like like decomposing wing it was real
that Sony once turned down the offer to
buy all of Marvel's properties for only
twenty five million dollars this is of
course long before their current value
of several billion I mean while I keep
trying to sell my Sony Walkman for
twenty five billion dollars and I got a
buyer Sam is very bad with money
next up the 2015 Colt action comedy film
a kung fury is being made into a feature
film starring Michael Fassbender David
Hasselhoff and Arnold Schwarzenegger
meanwhile my conferee next up here we go
Justice League released its deleted
scenes which include a scene showing
Superman considering to put on a black
Superman suit but he saved it for the
funeral scene of the don't know I don't
know I just wanted to make a black
Superman joke being steel and then Shaq
and then I backtracked and then I
explained everything and then when will
I stop talking and it just got funnier
and finally here we go a number of lego
sets for the upcoming of enters infinity
war movie have revealed key plot details
about the film including without
spoiling anything
a new weapon used by thor it's a symbol
[Laughter]
they are not to scale exactly that size
that's great yeah okay well Sam take it
away
Oh going with Santa all right
nope no we're not all right guys it's
why it's me it says say it whoo this is
what a winner looks like all right big
thanks to our hosts Eric when does the
audience come out from the SNL set going
hey Philip yeah blow make sure you go
watch out your dogs you know this really
went off the rails for the bones new
rock stars get out of here we're done
okay yeah comment down below tweet us
share this video around like it
subscribe to new rock stars deep dives
on all the stuff you love guys see you
next week